hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to species artificial life
real evolution so what this is do you
remember a game that I played a while
ago that was kind of like a artificial
intelligence like simulator style thing
that was trying to evolve a species and
control some muscles on a creature this
is supposed to get the entirety of the
evolutionary process for a creature like
spore dad looks perfectly normal nothing
wrong with that I don't know what any of
this is let's just go for it like spore
but not I have no idea how there's gonna
be to be perfectly honest so we're just
gonna find out fins and flippers update
click on a creature to select it and get
info and tools drag a box around
multiple creatures to interact with them
all at once ok freemum species
oh oh it's sleeping oh it's horrible
it's a horrible penis monster that's
sleeping oh yeah create your basic stats
when you got the creature selected gasp
did it just gasp you can see their state
over there on the right their state more
details by clicking the tab buttons
above energy Oh physiology genetics oh
whoa creature physiology oh my god
there's so much stuff oh my god why is
there so much stuff ok I guess I'm on my
own now right what what is this nursery
applied radiation radiation
Rover's what oh oh God dr o why is it
why is it in the ocean what well why
music now oh my god this Rover don't
control too good
ok oh my god genetic engineering whoa oh
oh god horrible okay so everyone calm
down all of you are screaming right now
you're screaming at the heavens you're
like what the hell is going on what is
that thing why does it look like a penis
like just everybody hold on to your hats
for a second this is our baby it may not
seem like our baby but
our baby it's crawling for Mama looking
for a boobie to suck on its its hoping
and praying that it's gonna survive the
cold cold night of winter and it's our
job to um I don't know make sure it
doesn't die or something like that but
this is our baby this is our baby so we
got to make sure that we evolve it in a
weird way brain gluttony what oh my god
number of features facial features I
don't think I could just change anything
could I know done luckily doesn't make
it double inside oh okay all right
generate all right corty mimiama gay
okay what does that do
it didn't do nothing it did nothing all
right
um that did the dick and diddly okay
everybody forget about our baby for now
baby didn't happen no baby made today no
no no babies okay no babies all right
what just happened what have you died
all right whatever we're gonna get out
of here we need to get this something I
don't know what we need I'm so confused
all right uh yeah this is normal guys
normal okay all right well Rover over
where you go over okay I'm just gonna
pop out here we off this sea takes wide
turns Scott like quite an ass on it that
just likes to swing out really sashays
is it turns oh my god really really
really really Oh autosave yeah and now
the music stops I don't understand what
the hell's going on there's got to be
some way that I can affect these
creatures that's got to be the point
right increase land fertility well
there's got to be some way that I can
change these creatures right okay wait
hang in here yo how do I get out of this
goddamn Rover Rover get out of here
delete so I want to grab one of you guys
and I wanna here we go
artificially inseminate the selected
creatures with saved DNA from another
creature number one gross and number two
I don't have any other save DNA I've
used it all I'm so they're things you
don't need to worry about I don't know
where my DNA is move point okay you're
in whoa what dial
hello Rover um why are you in here all
right so you're winded you're gonna do
it
as well oh you're dead what where did
you come from the start spot oh my god
did it just start like gushing out
babies was it like a spider's nest full
of eggs and it just decided to scooch
out like that because that's horrible
dad that's horrible okay all right so uh
Wow
what excuse me um edit target oh okay
all right um let's see I'm gonna go for
bigness we're gonna we're gonna go for
big okay or not we go for big hey can we
go for why do you not make sense why
can't I click there we go we're gonna
aim for we're aiming for bigness that's
where we're aiming for that's our goal
select target number import import
creature genome huh important what Oh
what's happening I have no idea what's
happening they're just exploding into
meat why are they exploding into meat I
don't know what's happening but there's
meat everywhere delicious meat left
behind by a premium species okay but I
mean they don't I mean they do seem to
be exploding into meat but not 100% sure
why are you killing them this Rover is
this Rover killing oh no the rover's
dropping no it's killing them
no it's killing them this Rover is
destroying them why are you doing Rover
are you trying to kill all the ones that
aren't going towards the desired outcome
is that what's happening here cuz it's
the only thing I can think of oh [ __ ]
they've changed wait what whoa he's got
horns that's weird
our baby has horns guys good news or
baby has horns oh wow I'm gonna call you
horny oh you're cute you know not bad
not bad
uh let's uh get more radiation in there
or something I don't know maybe that'll
help can we get like five radiation we
got five times the normal radiation
apparently Oh what is what is that is
that our baby what happened to our baby
is huge
oh it's butthole is increased is that a
tongue Oh
is either a butthole or a mouth and I
don't know which one's more disturbing
yeah well keep going I guess we've gone
down this path I don't know where it's
gonna go oh my god oh my god oh my god
do not eat the rover oh my god what is
happening it's way different than what's
outside if I let these creatures out
they would kill everything they're so
big you got legs orbit what are you what
the hell it is sport don't look at me
do not [ __ ] look at me don't you dare
okay I don't know what the hell this is
but uh Wow okay alright
what you got a butt hole for a face you
got butt cheeks your butt you do not
look at me don't look don't you know you
look at me I do not like that I do not
like that stop it so uncomfortable okay
it's dead thank you good it's dead that
didn't live long probably for the best
alright cool this is going horribly
wrong this just proves to me that I
should not be in charge of anything that
has to do with the lives of others I am
an irresponsible overlord
it's horrifying okay you I don't know
pre malice Monty seeum I don't know how
exactly to save one of these bad boys
that's got arms to that's no good okay
well I'll just let it keep going cuz I
don't know how to save them at this
point I know so little about the game
that I'm just best off letting him why
oh just splooshed out more babies that
are dying very very quickly this thing's
been living a long time you know oh no
no I just had to talk okay that species
is instinct so the only species that hat
oh they're fighting what the [ __ ] whoa
well they don't like each other
well now we're kind of back to the
originator this is like where it was
before we were on the right track and
then they just died like we were on the
right track with like legs and arms and
then they just died I wish I could have
saved to the DNA or something like that
why are they all congregated in that
corner they're not moving why do they
keep dying oh they can't breathe I keep
saying they're seeking oxygen but I
don't know what that
we're gonna increase the land fertility
I guess fertility increasing increasing
increasing increasing I don't know where
this metric is hat is kept but going for
it whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a minute
things are happening outside of the pen
- I didn't even realize there's other
creatures that are getting adaptations
these have arms
that's a weird oh this is bizarre these
guys are still clonked up in the corner
over here doing who-knows-what because
they're suffocating it it says Oh - what
is that what is that why don't they have
any oxygen why is there no oxygen wait
where's the oxygen there's no food if
there's no food what do they eat so
there's no oxygen and there's no food
but it was a mean they're all starving
how do we feed them huh
how do we feed him oh wow
Oh weird the dominant species is primum
species which is the original I think
but uh these guys are not getting fed
which is bizarre maybe because there's
no actual grass there maybe they need
grass I don't know or whatever I'm gonna
take this one creature and I'm gonna put
him outside the pen and died okay I'm
gonna take the biggest one here you I'm
gonna take you and I'll put you outside
the pen and he's life no he's alive and
he's dead okay well they do in survive
there's so many on this island over here
I guess I did increase the land
fertility like a lot I mean everything's
just dying in here I have no idea how to
create oxygen how do you create oxygen
okay so I think I'm starting to
understand a little bit of this game
there's a lot less that I can do whoa
you are funkalicious are those eye holes
are those like rudimentary eye holes
don't like oh it is oh god it's a
horrible face why is it a face okay so
all right the thing about this game is
this there there are things that I can
do to control it like what I've been
trying to do and not succeeding at but
there are some things that you can do to
control it but a lot of it is just left
up to the game itself like the game is
about randomly producing different
results all over the place like just
changing up all the time you know I I
can't always do what I want to do
God look at these things they're
starting to look like seals weird and
weight lean Jean splice where do I get a
G where do I get the genome Bank I don't
know where I get the genome Bank from
look at this butt face
did I just do it
I did okay so that's how you export man
I wish I had that bipedal thing they
actually had legs very nice okay so I'm
gonna take you with the do not look at
me don't you dare don't you look at me
oh my god don't look at me good yeah
okay you're gonna go in here I'm gonna
take you you're gonna go in here I'm
gonna take you with some of your buds
and you're gonna go in here and oh and
you're dead okay
all right never mind how about you you
and your buds aren't you you're going in
and you're dead okay cool and how about
you all right you right there is it the
radiation it might be the radiation and
it might very much be the radiation okay
let's see and the rover kills it oh wait
a minute
is the rover killing it because it
doesn't it's not on the way to this
evolution am i picking up what you're
putting down how did we clear a target
entirely let me just take everything in
here we're gonna move it out so there's
nothing in the pen anymore and I bet
they all died too cuz they're they don't
seem like they're gonna do too well
scariest thing I've ever seen in my
entire life okay you you're coming in
here now
boink now you're a part of this yeah
pretty cool all right and oh you don't
get murdered I see I see I see so you
are the new hotness this Rovers making
sure y'all breed right yeah okay it's a
little too hot a little too hot but you
know I can lower the temperature a bit
it radiates interest so I could just
douse you with radiation I can resurrect
oh that's that's a power I shouldn't
have resurrecting animals I definitely
shouldn't have that
this is trying to go to that that's not
what we're gonna try to do can we clear
this out how do we clear out what we're
trying to go for how do we do that I
don't
want to go for this don't go for this I
want to go for more I want to do more
bigger edit target but it's still this
how do I clear that out you genetic
engineering alright so we're gonna okay
maybe it's like this okay I want
freakishly big is what I want I want big
we're going for big right there is
absolutely no way in hell to ever get
this thing to look like that thing so
why do I even bother I don't know it
cannot be changed ever for the history
of forever now and forever it will not
be changed what is that oh no it's
morphing back toward its root it's
referring that's not what I want god oh
that's not what I wanted I've ruined a
perfectly good species now it's oh god
it's reverting oh it's reverting in
horrible ways because I can't figure out
how to frickin change this thing edit
target there's died there's nothing
there's nothing you there's no there's
no like option there's no fool all right
you know what that's okay because we're
just gonna kill everything put it
outside it'll all die who cares let
nature take its course and once I know
how to do whatever I'm doing that's what
I'll do
this is no way to change it that's so so
strange okay let's just let it go for a
bit let's get it let's let it go for a
bit we're just gonna we're gonna let it
go these creatures they're gonna evolve
at their own rate they're gonna do their
own thing and then we're just gonna you
know watch we're just gonna watch we're
just gonna observe because every time I
try to intervene they die hey these six
have four legs and weird spikes but they
got four legs
hey looking like hippos over here okay
right that's a thing this is a horrible
horrible thing it's a horrible horrible
thing that I've created
I didn't even create it I tried to
create world I don't like that or to
waggy tail that's no good oh that's
that's not that's the opposite of good
don't wag it don't like it more when I'm
don't don't be happy I hope that's happy
whatever that is don't do that there's a
lot less life on this island than there
once was and I think it has to do with
me and my proclivity to irradiate things
like you letsa radiate you
are you dead yet not yet but your
offspring will be really weird on your
dead well that didn't work maybe two
irradiated you are you actually Oh with
the face good earn it with radiation
okay let's see how that does yeah huh
okay you're dead okay how about just a
little radiation huh just a little there
we go that's a nice dose that's a nice
dose you're gonna die okay there and you
died by swimming into the ocean for some
reason oh you are old you're so old are
you so old revived man dead and revived
live again you hungry and you're dead
okay you got to stop dying that's really
your your main flaw here there you go
now he's going for it in a radiator he's
good this one's good this one's gonna
live no it's fighting never mind it's
fighting yeah you're gonna die why do
you suck do you know what I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna radiate all of you all of
you and some of you are gonna survive
right now dead dead dead dead dead dead
dead dead dead dead ahh not alive okay
that's good that's good there we go this
is not great
they're all dead you know what if you
think if you think that I'm just gonna
sit around and let bygones be bygones no
I'm not I'm not this island oh this is
the radiation Island pump up the jams
Pump It Up pump it way up you know what
do you got going on now nothing because
you're changing you're gonna look so
weird this is the island of
experimentation the center islet is not
the island of experimentation that's the
island of death because nothing can stay
alive here but here oh yeah a radiant
pumped up the rads pom-pom up OH two
species looks like there might have been
a new species on that island because the
radio there's a lot less creatures on
this island than there were once prot
there there's a lot less there's way way
way low my goodness slow whoo you're
tough you get a lot of health I'm gonna
save you and eat it rise my champion
okay so maybe maybe you like flooding
them with radiation isn't the best idea
but it's like the only thing that I know
how to do at this point I'm gonna infuse
you
with this our import there you've been
spliced twelve species what the hell
twelve species that doesn't even make
any sense why there's so many species
what is that need them feed them yeah
feed them
Oh radiate them feed them keep their
bellies full and their brains are
radiated that's how you do yeah we're
gonna feed them oh yeah everything here
yeah you guys getting fed and we're
gonna splice you again with whatever the
hell this is yeah get spliced and
radiated and fed yeah feed yeah yeah
yeah how do you like them apples
yeah but they just weird and radiated if
I just keep feeding him in a radiating
them and feeding him in a radiating them
and feeding them and feed and radiated
feeding and feeding feeding feeding I
gotta keep him alive alive alive
radiations alive oh there we go now
we're talking oh there's something tough
in here look at all this well this look
at this you yeah from Ellis pemon or
you're weird I like you or boa den drab
yeah you're barb oh uh yeah barb hola
yeah okay all right feet feet feet feet
all right see now I feel like I actually
have something I can do I mean it's not
a good thing this is gonna create a
horror show of the worst traits coming
in it's gonna be like the most deformed
island in the entire archipelago but hey
it feels good to do something feels like
I'm helping you know by shooting them
full of radiation it really feels like
I'm helping alright let me just give it
like another five minutes they they've
been fed it's time to see which one of
them's gonna Duke it out now that I have
stopped feeding them you know what I
mean I'll give it like 36 but 30 seconds
on the clock
[Music]
I have no idea how much time has gone on
but a lot of people have gone extinct so
let's see who's the duel what look at
this guy look at this guy
what the hell I don't like you at all
you're horrifying look at that guy
whoa you got tiger stripes why you're so
cool what are you oh you're awful I hate
you as a feet click door Adam yeah yeah
what about you Oh club foot
oh the big foot gritty insect Taurus Oh
what are you uh was everything what is
anything on this place
oh you wait whoa we might have a winner
that's an actual thing it's got a waggy
tail but that's an actual thing okay so
compare the life on this island versus
the life on say this island what are we
at ah we're still at worms oh you guys
you're still at worms you're not a worm
you're weird no I don't like you I don't
like the hair why do you have hair oh oh
why is it textured like skin ooh oh it's
worse oh god no it's more like a penis
than ever except hairy it's like a thumb
if someone a thumb for a dick Oh
obviously that's gross because that's
that's natural evolution would Blair
blue we want our freak show that's what
we're really dos up the rads ha
feed him feed him feed him feed him yeah
feed him feed him feed him raid raid
raid raid feed him feed him feed him
feeling rad rad rad rad now to let him
go whoa look at this big guy and he's
dead oh so weird oh god it's so weird
let me look at the do I be the clade
diagram okay who's the dominant species
right now oh my god what what oh my god
fossil yeah oh no gross a weird
a bizarre-o not okay
things have got in drastic directions
nah
I fall by the way not my fault that
things have gone in drastic directions
they just have in totally normal
circumstances in other places let's make
the waters more fertile it is pretty
impressive that they got hung Huynh
drudes of these little things all doing
their own little quests all tracking
their own little data because there are
a lot of them there's a lot of these
guys everywhere that's pretty impressive
yeah these things are kind of horrible
hey but this guy's got four legs but I
think those are invasive species from up
north so those aren't welcome here
really we're looking for Oh No su path
aqua taunus Oh No look at your dinky
feet Oh No all right let's time to
splice okay all right so now freakshow
Island I'll bow splice you with
something you probably don't want yeah
was that say Tia's folk tomb [ __ ] them
yes say Deus [ __ ] them that's what it is
okay you're gonna just combined with
these guys so uh have fun with that yep
and you're dead oh they'll they'll just
went into the ocean to die all right
well have babies Oh God oh oh oh no no
it literally just popped out an exact
clone that's not what you want to see
well anyway I guess that's just what
freakshow islands all about finding the
best the best that come from this
hellhole over here and putting it over
in the worst of the worst of in this
hellhole over here and then everyone
else is doing just you know their own
thing what are they looking like on this
island
you know big buck but I like that that's
pretty cool yeah that's not bad all
right what do we got going on over here
oh and let's see what a little tube like
but you know that's okay you'll work off
the winter weight someday oh you're
still horrible absolutely terrible okay
all right love that I hate that actually
oh man what do you got what do you got
oh you're even worse than the other one
okay everything's terrible everything's
horrible and I hate everything maybe we
should just get like a flood or
something and just kind of like raise
the oceans and just
wipe this place clean of all the sins
that I've obviously committed in the
name of evolutionary perfection so yeah
Oh everything died here there's not much
living there really not a lot that
survived from that fresh injection of
DNA I guess let's just keep blasting
them with radiation and see what happens
I'm just so fascinated is what's gonna
happen to these poor horrible creatures
oh this island is not like half the
population of the entire arc are Kubelik
archipelago whoops don't how do I not
move the okay I just move them all well
that was not my intention oh my God look
at all the things going extinct look at
all the things mutated just the list
never stops oh my god rise from the dead
oh [ __ ] well I might be goofin big I
might be doing big goof into this time
at this juncture I think I'm big goof in
it yeah I'm big goof in it real big ly
uh my FPS is tanked but uh yeah let's
just let this go for a bit um yeah Wow
oh it's a battle zone there's a debate
there since there's no single species at
this entire place well survival of the
fittest I guess what did I just see what
is that kill it
oh god kill it just just kill it you
deserve to die I'm sorry all right I'm
gonna decrease land fertility just
really tank it that way it'll have to be
like a survival of the fittest kind of
thing people will have to eat each other
that's what I want that's what you want
whoa whoa that's weird
whoa are those boobs or eyes what are
those that's bizarre okay all right I'm
gonna call you you're you're you're
challan kilis all right so you're
telling Gillis ah yes who's gonna infuse
the DNA of the poor inhabitants there's
like nothing left on this side there's
nothing left okay well you're getting
infused with your too long' colas all
right your challan colas get in there
Dan and really Shaw knows the business
see time feed him feed him all
make babies make babies with your
freakish DNA oh yeah I say yours child
shall long kill us all right yeah I
think Wow okay all right yeah this is a
freak show and this never should have
happened and I never should have been in
power of anything here so I think I'm
gonna leave this as it is um like this
is the kind of thing that you could just
let run in the background and be like
totally shocked of where things go as I
learn the game I probably could find
more and more ways of influencing things
and actually get people into my little
nursery here and figure out how to
change that but for now I don't know so
we're just gonna leave it as it yes so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down the
comments below if you want to play this
for yourself there's a link in the
description oh if you want to see my
spore series that's kind of like this
but a less horrifying end at the same
time more horrifying what what what are
you what what what are you what are you
what are you you freak you big buck give
me good look at you what are you you
freak oh my god you've rigged you free
look at you you chunk oh good God look
at you you're thicker than a brick house
gasp is right you know gasp is right
this one's gonna be thick Ulis Chong cop
Bullis Nicolas Chong cop lifts and the
last thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
select every single goddamn thing on
this entire goddamn island where'd the
sky come from everything is gonna get
infused with the DNA of Chong Keolis
thick Ulis Jon Coppola s' John Gillis is
gonna infest this entire island with his
DNA alright I think I've found the
template yep hemp is the one and let's
see how that treats them before I go
here oh no oh no oh no it's just a bunch
of tiny thick baby it's the worst thing
it's just a bajillion tiny thick babies
what of the plains are overrun with the
thick of Cheung Kong Kili Count Chocula
taking over everything yeah I gotta go
I gotta go I've done a lot of mistakes
to this island and I've I've permanently
changed everything okay I'm gonna leave
now so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know you thought down
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video bye
[Music]